he saved us  me and my brother  orphans of war  brought us to this paradise  to join the others  until we came of age  until he  summoned us  he called it  ascension day  five years ago daryl went to him  [Music]  now  it's my time  my dear child  your ascension is at hand  fear not  all the chosen before you have played  their part in my vision  i have something beautiful to show you  liar where's my brother  clever aria that fire that singular  determination  mine to wield  behold the fire thing  your brother is here somewhere like all  the other chosen  you alone will be its driving force  get  in  i'm not alone  [Applause]  it's over  a warframe  a relic  i will have to show you the future  myself  ugh  to think i almost wasted  this gift  daryl  oh  wow  [Music]  oh  [Music]  [Music]  goodbye daryl  [Music]  we'll keep you close tenno  [Music]  you